listen let's try and help people here
i'm told jb
i'm told word on the street is that you
have
a solution for a way that restaurants
can succeed during coronavirus that
restaurants can do a better business
during the quarantine tell us what it is
corner this is what it is all the
businesses out there that we
are normally that we frequent they have
cut down their capacities
because of the corona virus they don't
want people more than six feet from each
other
so here's what you do conan this is the
smartest thing ever now
instead of your restaurant your capacity
is 250
right you can't do 250 because of the
corona
you need six feet apart and you have
less tables so here's my muscle too so
all that is
lap seats it's called lap seat lap
seating
so what it is is if you got a group of
people right you all been tested you're
all clean
everything's good with you you sit on
each other's laps
so a whole family can stack up you know
you got your husband sitting down you
got the wife sitting on the husband's
lap
you got the son sitting on the mama's
lap and the daughter sitting on the
son's lap see like
that's like a people totem pole see you
you're all stacked up
that way you get more of a capacity now
it's gonna get a little messy when they
bring spaghetti to your table
but you stack up
instead of outward you step upward no i
mean
you can reach your capacity and you can
keep going with your normal revenue that
you are used to acquiring
and investment moving things go to the
moment sit let your lady
sit on your lap see and two two chairs
down
somebody else got that lady on their lap
and it's more cozy
you you know you can you can sit there
and get you get frisky sometimes in the
morning
man we're not gonna have any of that
it's gonna be nice i'm gonna tell you if
you said my mama if my ladies sit on my
lap
something's gonna happen something's
gonna happen it's gonna get frisky up in
that bad boy
i saw this issue you stack up all right
you stack up we're gonna get the word
out on stacking up you gotta stay zen
you gotta find your spirits and you've
gotta
stack it up